if you could teleport the earth to any
place in the universe what would you
want to look at in the night sky the
bright explosion of a supernova a black
hole passing over your house how about a
nebula
what would this gorgeous gas cloud look
like up close and how would the earth
change if it were inside it
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we lived inside of a nebula
what is a nebula anyway a nebula is a
giant cloud of dust and gas in
interstellar space
they are vast sometimes taking up
hundreds of light-years of space but
with all that size
they aren't massive a nebula the
diameter of the earth would only have a
mass of a few kilograms that's because
nebulae aren't very dense and that's why
if we lived inside one it wouldn't look
anything like what you might expect some
thirteen hundred and forty-four
light-years away from Earth is the Orion
Nebula the brightest nebula in our sky
it's 24 light-years across and has a
mass equivalent to two thousand suns if
the earth was formed inside it all you'd
see in the night sky would be this not
impressed I know I wasn't either it
turns out it's not that easy to see a
nebula when you look at the night sky to
your eye most galaxies in the universe
don't look anything like this more like
this and most nebulae are invisible
altogether your eyes aren't sensitive to
the kind of light a nebula produces but
look at the image taken by the Hubble
Space Telescope and you'll see a
beautiful gas cloud that doesn't mean
these beautiful images of space are fake
their colors just represent the light
waves that your eyes aren't able to
detect so if you had the Hubble
telescope would you be able to see a
nebula if you lived in one sorry to
disappoint you again but no
nebulae are pretty only when they're
hundreds of light-years away
they look thick and cloudy only because
you see the structures of light-years
and thickness once you're close to them
their light spreads out so much that you
can't see them you could fly your
spaceship right into the nebula and
never even know it
if the earth were inside a nebula the
only effect you'd see would be brighter
Aurora's unless the solar wind blew all
the nebular particles far away from the
planet how do we know we're not living
inside a nebula right now simple after
gathering the data on our own Sun we can
calculate the expected brightness of the
neighboring stars if we did live inside
a nebula we'd notice that our star was
much brighter compared to others the
nebula would be dimming the light coming
in from outside of it but don't be sad
we can't teleport the earth yet but we
may be able to travel to distant
exoplanets that experience incredible
light shows in the night sky but that's
a story for another what if
you